MIKE, MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> Mike: MERRY CHRISTMAS TO
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN HIS CHRISTMAS MESSAGE
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED FOR UNITY
AND RESPECT FROM HIS PRIVATE
CLUB IN PALM BEACH.
24 HOURS AGO THE PRESIDENT SAID
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI HATES
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND ALL
TRUMP VOTERS WHILE COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE IMPEACHMENT STALEMATE.
AND CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON IS
WITH THE DUELING NARRATIVES OUT
OF RESPECT FOR POLITICS.
>> FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP CHRISTMAS
BREAK BREAK DISCUSSING
IMPEACHMENT.
HE'S SPENDING THE HOLIDAY
PRIVATELY WITH THE FAMILY IN
MAR-A-LAGO.
THEY ARE DEBATING THIS.
>> WE GIVE THANKS TO THE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO COME
TOGETHER TO MAKE TO CARE FOR
OTHERS WITH COMPASSION AND BRING
THE WARMTH AND BLISS OF THIS
HOLY SEASON TO OUR FAMILIES, OUR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS AND THOSE
IN NEED OF.
FOR CHRISTMAS DINNER, HOW TO WIN
AN ARGUMENT WITH YOUR LIBERAL
RELATIVES.
THAT ARMS TRUMP SUPPORTER US
WITH SUGGESTIONS TO SNOWFLAKES
OR SIBLINGS BY BOASTING ABOUT
THE ECONOMY OR TRADE AGREEMENTS.
THE DEMOCRATS CONTEND THE
PRESIDENT DID WITHHOLD AID FROM
UKRAINE TO COMPEL ITS PRESIDENT
TO INVESTIGATE THE BIDENS AND A
WEEK AGO THE HOUSE IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT ON PARTISAN LINES ON
THAT CHARGE.
>> I HOPE WE ARE ALL GOING TO
FIND A WAY, HOW WE ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT THE FACTS AND THESE
SENATORS WILL BE ALL IMPARTIAL
AND MAKE UP THEIR MIND AND WE
ARE ALL GOING TO PROTECT THE
DEMOCRACY THAT WE LOVE.
>> HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI IS
WITHHOLDING THE IMPEACHMENT
ARTICLES TO TRY TO FORCE SENATE
REPUBLICANS TO ALLOW WITNESSES
AND ANY IMPEACHMENT TRIALS.
REPUBLICAN
SENATOR LISA MURKOWSKI OF ALASKA
JUST TOLD A LOCAL TELEVISION
STATION THAT SHE WAS DISTURBED
WHEN SHE HEARD MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL WAS IN TOTAL
COORDINATION WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THE SENATE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
THERE IS ONE MORE HOLIDAY
MESSAGE FROM THE PRESIDENT THIS